[Music]
on today's show we talked to an awesome
mom who recently lost a toddler and
she's pregnant dealing with grief and
guilt we talked to a woman who's
soon to be in-laws won't take the
pictures down at the x
we talked to a guy who just wants to get
the romance back in his marriage stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey good morning everybody or good
afternoon or good evening or good night
i hope you're doing well this is john
with the dr john dolone's show
james started cranking music up outside
my keys on the desk we're just showing
up here but james is ready to go and
that means we are too we're so glad that
you're with us
talking about mental health
relationships
challenges tragedies good stuff anything
that's going on in your life and man
we've got a lot going on in our lives
all of us and so i'm here to walk with
you um if you want to be on the show
give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
ask a a-s-k
hey james kelly i'm going to
call an audible here okay
um how do i do this
how do i call out here
i'm going to call somebody
all this technology hello
scott
john
did i wake you up before you're normally
awake
no
you sound like you're asleep
that's just because i have a manly deep
voice in the morning i i strongly
disagree
hey listen two things number one you're
live on the show so don't say anything
bad
uh
number two
dude yesterday was your birthday and i
have a show where i teach people how to
be good family members and i missed your
birthday like a scumbag loser
and so let's call to tell you good
morning and happy birthday yesterday
well thank you i appreciate that you're
a great brother and i kind of suck
and hey listen um yesterday
i was uh on the show with dave and
somebody was just talking about what a
great uh big brother they had and i felt
bad for you because i kind of sucked at
it but i'm getting better and it starts
today right so next year i won't miss
your birthday but dude happy birthday
what'd you all do last night
i appreciate it uh
what did we do last night oh brandy joe
had to go to a
sorority thing she was a sponsor
so we celebrated my birthday on tuesday
night
probably something we shouldn't talk
about on the show though right
there's there's a happy porch like that
and then had a nice dinner and since i
am your brother uh wouldn't got
pedicures it was great you got you got a
pedicure
heck yeah i did
i'm sorry there seems to be a
disconnection in the line i can't hear
you
hey you know what dude whatever works
man whatever works
but congratulations happy birthday man
it's awesome good morning you know
i'm glad i don't feel so bad that your
wife skipped it to go to a sorority
event or whatever that is but good for
you man hey happy uh happy birthday i'm
glad you're my brother brother see you
dude
appreciate it
that's it
pedicures huh
he has a manly deep voice he can afford
to get pedicures
he's bigger than me like
2x i would have paid money to see him
getting a pedicure i think we should all
go get pet let's go do that
i am totally on board with that all
right good that's what the show's doing
everyone back there we're all going to
go do this soon especially zach's
excellent first we're going to go do
this it'll be awesome all right so happy
birthday and by the way
way to go deloney um the guy telling
everybody how to have good mental health
and relationships and friendships
me and james were at band practice with
our metal band and i didn't even call my
little brother until i'm happy birthday
what an idiot but we fixed it today so
there we go all right uh let's go to
tynan in kansas city kansas hey tynan
how are you
i'm doing well how about yourself we are
rocking and rolling so what in the
world's going on how can i help
yes
um so the reason i called is um we lost
our 14 month old daughter earlier this
month and a drowning incident oh
god hardest days of our lives absolutely
you're still in the middle of them
we are yeah we definitely are yeah oh my
goodness were you there
uh yes i was um my husband was not and
he had to travel a couple hours to get
to us oh man i'm so so sorry
oh thank you thank you
um
so we have two older kids a four and a
half year old and a three-year-old and
then we have a new baby due in six weeks
oh my gosh
yeah so my question for you so you're
super super pregnant right now
yeah uh babies due at the end of october
it'll be here any time
that laugh that you just gave was
was not a funny laugh it was a is this
happening left right
yeah this is life yeah
for sure it's the guy at the bar that
realizes oh we're getting into fist
fight and he smiles that's what you just
did
so yeah
um so in six weeks you're having another
baby right in the baby wow okay can i
can i ask you something um
real i mean we're in a personal
conversation here
yeah you sound incredibly detached
is that where you've had to park for the
last couple of weeks
um
yes
yes and no okay um you know
yeah after the incident um you know our
daughter fought really hard for a week
so we were in the picu for a week
and um
yeah i'm very frustrated
that i was pregnant because i wanted all
of my energy and stuff to be
you know for her um and it was hard to
take care of myself and this baby during
that and then um
yeah and then we we lost her and you
know and then the weeks have gone on and
yeah
yeah it's yeah so i guess my question
through that is how are we supposed to
navigate through the grief and the guilt
in a way that also allows us to fully
experience
the joy of bringing another new life
into this world
um from our previous kids we know it's
going to be amazing but at the same time
we just have this profound sadness that
makes it seem like this is going to be a
bittersweet miracle
yeah
it is
yeah
one of the things that you're
putting on yourself right now is a
right way to do this
and it you've got a picture of what your
other three births were that joy and the
in the chaos and the laughter and the
late nights and all that stuff
but there's that under
underneath that foundational sense of
joy and connection and this is our
family
and
you're imposing that on this situation
it's a totally different situation
yeah
and
one of the cornerstones of of
grief that melts people is expectation
on how it's supposed to go
yeah that's the hardest thing it is it's
so hard
and so for you letting go
of this idea that you're gonna be
stealing from this new kid you're not
this baby's gonna be loved so
unimaginably deep
and this baby was born in the back end
of a pandemic just just was right this
baby was born in the middle of the
darkest moments of
his or her parents entire life
and that's just a reality for this kid
does that mean your kid's gonna love be
loved less no does that mean mom and dad
are gonna sometimes have to hand the
baby off and go weep on all fours in
their in their room alone yes it does
and so
what you and your husband have to do is
let go of the it should be like this
and experience the it is like this
and then you've got to be extra
intentional about having people around
you they're going to walk with you
through this season because it's going
to be different it's going to be hard
yeah and that's been the hardest thing
for us is being vulnerable to letting
other people help help us
um we have been blessed with amazing
family friends and a small community and
um that's that is definitely the hardest
part is being vulnerable
so my guess is
your ability to talk with me right now
and articulate things the way you are
lets me know that you are
you are still fully in
um
fight or flight you're still
you're still gunning does that make
sense
yeah and it could be because you're
pregnant it could be you have two little
ones and you don't have time because
they've got to eat and have their
diapers changed and they got to get to
where they got to get
and husbands still got to go earn a live
all those things right
um yeah
you must make space for this
because it's it'll come for you okay
yeah and that's not a bad thing that's a
good thing that's how we're designed but
you've that's that
so here's a couple of things let me let
me back out a little bit um
you will at
over time be able to pull apart the
grief from the guilt okay
what i don't want you to do is to add
any more guilt
in the future than what you're already
carrying
does that make sense okay so you're
going to try your said than done of
course it is so here's what's really
important
is making sure you've got a daily
journaling practice where you're writing
these things down and what that does is
it keeps them from settling in
for lack of better terms this analogy
it keeps them from settling in your
backpack and becoming part of you
okay okay and so having a steady flow if
you and your husband are able to do this
together it's really great is you read
these out loud
and okay there's something profound
grief demands a witness
and so this often wrecks families and
here's why because there becomes this i
need you just to be done with this or
why are you still worried about this or
he grieves like this and you grieve like
that
and it's the expectation on how we
should be grieving and what we should be
doing by now and it's been four months
or it's been two years or it's been
whatever or we're taking the pictures
off the wall no we're not and there's
not space for people to grieve on their
own but you don't grieve alone you
grieve together you just do it
differently
and so the way you do that is checking
in with one another and just being
gracious with space because everybody
does it different does that make sense
okay
yep that makes sense and so
it's less about we need to do these
things
and more about
30 minutes every day we're gonna check
in with one another all kids are out
we're not gonna be around their kids and
even if that means we're gonna have to
get a neighbor to come over for an hour
and evening
and just let us have some space and
we're gonna look at each other in the
eyes and say where are you
and they're gonna say i'm okay and then
there's gonna be seasons where you feel
guilty because you don't feel bad that
day right yeah or you're gonna have days
that you wake up and you're running
around with two kids and you go into
appointment and then you didn't think
about
your baby the past and then you're gonna
all of a sudden be overwhelmed with
guilt and what kind of mom am i and all
those are things you gotta write down
and process with somebody okay
okay okay and over time that grief and
guilt will pull apart so
i
knew this call was coming and i called a
close buddy of mine who's a licensed
therapist who also experienced something
similar
and um
he gave me some really great
um insight and happened to be pregnant
in the very very similar he wasn't
pregnant obviously his wife was but um
they were going through the same thing
yeah one of the things he strongly
recommended is to let you know
that this baby
will not be a replacement
this isn't gonna be an instead of and it
might feel like that way right now once
you hold this baby you'll know that
they're not
yeah and he strongly recommended keeping
pictures up i asked him i said you still
have pictures up and he actually took a
picture of the wall with all his kids
photos
and he's got the picture of his youngest
still there and they celebrate birthdays
so it just becomes the rhythm of your
family right good okay there's not a
right or way to do this that's the key
there
okay
being certain whether you put up
stockings at christmas
whether you said a place at thanksgiving
and everybody writes a letter and puts
it in her stocking or puts it you know
whatever those things are will become a
rhythm of your family
and it's the things that don't keep you
from not crying that's not the point the
point is that yeah
in love right
yes how's husband doing
he's he's doing pretty good um yeah we
have my four and a half year old we have
happy sad days where parts of our days
are happy and parts of our days are sad
and that is just so true
so can i tell you the greatest greatest
greatest gift you can give your kids
yes please do is let them see you be sad
yes let them see you grieve
um if you all decide hey we're going to
draw a picture uh what was the baby
who's passed what was what was her name
her name was clara yeah
they draw a picture for clara
they write a note to clara even if you
write maybe a a elevated note to clara
and you read it to them and let them
know that you really miss clara
and it shows them that it's okay that
they miss clara
yeah you know what i mean
and when you next time the kids are
gonna go swimming and your heart rate
takes off
you can hold their hands and tell them
hey mommy's nervous
because i miss clara and they'll get
that and they won't feel crazy does that
make sense yeah
that makes total sense yeah the tendency
is to hide our feelings because we don't
scare our little kids and what it does
is it makes them feel terrified of their
own feelings because they're scared too
yeah
yeah and if dad cries and he can hold
your two little ones and
the brand new baby all of it right
i'm heartbroken for you
thank you
thank you we yeah we
we miss her terribly but we also have
100 confidence that she is healed and
she's cold and she is perfect in heaven
and
we will see her again it doesn't take
away the pain of missing her down here
but
that's that's the confidence we could
have right now so one of the the great
demons of these kind of of these seasons
that i've seen over and over and over is
a lot of really
well-meaning people
say the worst things
and yeah
you get flooded with dumb books and
internet links and blah blah blah okay
so i don't want to pile up on that
um i do want to recommend you and your
husband pick up a book called
finding meaning by david kessler
and he is the world's renowned grief
expert it's the single greatest book my
career has been in grief and this is the
greatest book i've ever read and what
makes it beautiful and unique is he's
the top scientist in the world
when it comes to grief
and then he lost his son
and
the the the narrative that weaves
through the book is i wanted to go back
and hug every parent i ever sat with
because i didn't get it and now i do
and the book is a masterpiece on walking
through things like
when those images pop back in your head
and you think they're going to take take
you know take over right yeah yeah and
here's how you do that here's how you
move on here's how you can let those
things go and here's how you don't
become captive by those by those
thoughts that pop in your head or those
pictures that pop in your head or
i can't get this one particular scene
out of my mind or your heart just starts
raining those kind of things
it's a masterpiece walking through
each one of those situations and i think
you and your husband should read it
together and um when you're ready and it
could be a really shape-shifter for your
family
awesome we will definitely do that then
cool so i want to tell you
it's a blessing to talk to you you're a
gift and
so many people out there deal with grief
in such deep and profound ways and
i'm grateful that you shared your story
with us
thank you thank you i appreciate your
advice i really do well we'll be
thinking about you please when you're um
new baby what's girl or boy coming
surprise surprise
do you have a name yet because john is
amazing
i'll let my husband know he's really big
in the name so
i just think john's a great name that's
all i'm saying james terrible name do
not name james but john might be a great
name that's all i'm saying and um when
the surprise is born if you will send us
a photo let us know and we will be
cheering you on
okay i will do that awesome hey thank
you so so much for the call thank you
for your vulnerability
um you've got millions of people
thinking about you guys and
grateful for the call hey we'll be right
back on the dr john alone show
[Music]
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important your
mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy for you video
chat phone or even text chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you become a better version of
yourself help you get on the road to
being well go to
betterhelp.com for 10 off your first
month this is less expensive than
traditional therapy and you're worth it
betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
all right we are back hey um real quick
before we go to the next call i want to
um circle back to that last call
i think this is important to note
everybody does grief different
and
some people buckle down and go to
therapy right away and they get a trauma
counselor and they surround themselves
with friends and they're vulnerable some
people lock it down some people have two
little kids
and
another child on the way
and
they detach completely and they are they
i've got to go through the motions
almost become robotic if you will
and some people become inconsolable and
i can't move right
all that to say is this a lot of people
we we assume that oh he hasn't cried yet
he's not dealing with this maybe
maybe
oh she has turned into uh um she's able
to speak very clearly and robotically
she's not handling this well maybe
one of the worst things we can do when
we're trying to love people um who are
grieving is to
tell them that it looks like this
it looks like that you know it's been
four months you also go ahead and get
rid of all the clothes
you still have pictures up you should
it's the idea of you should
you should
the only shoulds that should happen when
somebody's in in the throes of grief
is that
they've got to have people around them
they've got to eat
and to the best that they're able to
they go to sleep and move their body
um and so you'll all when i show up in
situations like this when i have friends
who are going through deep deep grief
we celebrate little wins um a friend of
mine just posted today um just went and
got a car after um she lost a loved one
in a car wreck that was a big deal to go
buy uh her first car and a car that's
gonna keep her and family safe and so
there's these little winds man and you
cheer the crap out of those because
they're huge and they're milestones and
they're things that most people just
blow by
you'll hear me always say hey are you
eating
are you going to bed
are you just mindlessly scrolling is
somebody coming over to sit with you
whoever they happen to be someone mowing
your yard right
other than that there's just not a right
or wrong way to do this
if you've got somebody who is constantly
looping on i can't get that picture out
of my head um
my son passed away and i just keep
picturing him here picturing him here
picturing him here a trauma counselor
can help with that that's not always
your deal sometimes it's just to hold
their hand give him a hug
say i'm so so sorry
um but it's this idea of imposing should
should should and as people who love
other people who are hurting
let's keep our shoulds to a minimum
and let's just show up we don't do good
as a society with silence let's just
show up okay
um i was like i'm just so honored to
have been able to speak to her and her
family's got a long long road
ahead a long road
um
and they're gonna need people just to
sit with him and say hey we love you so
we're bringing casserole
all right let's go to alicia in los
angeles hey alicia what's going on
hi dr john thank you so much for taking
my call thank you for calling i'm a huge
fan of you of you oh my gosh so what's
up how's it going
it's going okay um so my 31 year old
boyfriend was previously married okay
and i'm wondering how to navigate
i guess conversations and expectations
about his old wedding photos and photos
with his ex
which are still fairly prominent
all over the house and
on his social media here and there
um he's taken them down but just all
over you know family and and friends and
it's not just
you know if you do a deep dive you can
find photos of anything i mean dave
ramsey says that
the devil but but i mean it's right
there when you click
on it so regarding his mom and his dad
does he have kids
no no kids okay
oh so his parents still have these
photos up
correct
okay
does he still have photos up in his
house
he's got one framed collage with her in
it um you know they were high school
sweethearts so they've got over 10 years
of history
and
i'm fine with you know a prom photo of
your ex-girlfriend but i feel like in
this case that's that's his ex-wife so
for me it
it impacts me a little bit more um oh
alicia you're not gonna like my answer
okay here's the thing
i can do one of two things i can super
lie to you and it would be way more fun
for me or i can just tell you the truth
which one do you want
absolutely the truth
okay
so how long have you been dating this
dude
a year but we recently went ring
shopping
gross okay curious so you went ring
shopping
okay so you say like you look him in the
eye and you get all like fluttery and
you say i love you and things like that
y'all are there
yes we are there uh-huh and is is he
the one you're
choosing absolutely
okay so you're in on this dude
i am okay
so
[Laughter]
i'm trying to be nice because you sound
so lovely
um
here's the thing you're marrying her too
and
she's a part of his life
she's his high school sweetheart she was
his wife
they've got a decade in together
and one of the things that's going to be
so tempting and so frustrating
is that you're going to always know that
she has 10 more years with him than you
do
and you're going to have to let that go
or you're going to drown the
relationship
in
in competition a competition you can't
catch up with
your job isn't to be the a better wife
or the better one or the prettier one or
the one who like that when you when
you're when you try to get into that
lane you put him in a situation that he
can't possibly win
you force his family into this weird
thing
my guess is eat one of two things either
he screwed up and they still like her my
parents like my wife more than me there
is no question about that
right
and my mom has even said as such like
just just so we're all clear if i ever
left my wife she's able to go stay with
them i am not like so we've had that
conversation that will fade over time
right so who knows what's in their heart
and head if they're making a move if
this is like a middle finger to you
or they're just 111 years old and they
don't know how to take old photos like
what you know what i mean like some some
parents aren't that savvy
if they're not they're not
okay
so they are not fans of her whatsoever
um she
decided to end the marriage kind of
shortly in due to differences in
finances and not wanting to start a
family with him okay um so
to them you know she broke his heart and
you know we've talked about it many
times so they're they're not huge fans
so okay i'm just a little perplexed as
to why okay why when i click on it
that's like the first thing that pops up
still i think it's more because they're
a little more archaic and haven't gotten
to updating the photo so as a person my
wife tells me my wife tells me all the
time like i was born in the wrong
century so the last thing i would think
to do is to go change a photo on the
internet
that's just me and
so what i would do if i was you
is let the imaginary internet world be
the imaginary internet world who cares
okay and if it makes you nutty don't
click on it don't go to their pages
and at some point when you're engaged or
you're married and they say why don't
you ever comment on our post you could
say
oh gosh because that girl's still on
there i don't want to see her and you
can laugh about it and they'll go oh my
goodness does that make sense it's it's
the spirit you're gonna bring to this
thing
and it is this she is a part of his life
forever
she is
and you've got to be okay with that
and
she's not a part of she is not his wife
anymore you're gonna be
and so you've got to rest in that
assurance that he picked you
ugh y'all are ring shopping
he picked you yeah you won you won okay
does that make sense
that makes sense and you cannot compete
against her that's not an event
that's something that just gonna make
you nuts and make him nuts does that
make sense
oh yeah and it has been mm-hmm it's got
on
if here here's a cool thing you can do
two things number one
take this poor little boy
like i did that he's not he's a grown
old 31 year old man
take him out to dinner and say
i have been trying to size myself up
against your ex-wife i'm not doing that
anymore i love you and we're into this
thing and i know that
and he's going to be weirded out he's
going to have moments when he thinks
you're just going to break his heart
because it's already happened to him
he's going to have moments when he
misses her
he's going to have moments where there's
a ten-year-old inside joke that he's
gonna lean over to tell you and realize
oh you don't know that joke
that because they went to high school
together does that make sense
and you've gotta go it's not about me
because he loves me and he's i'm i'm his
husband
and spending time trying to go back and
scorch the race to all that it's just
gonna just melt the guy
right okay
this is gonna be tough but you're gonna
have to be a grown-up about it you're
marrying a guy that's divorced okay so
you're marrying all of him and he's
probably going to be an amazing husband
because he knows what heartbreak feels
like and he knows what attention feels
like is that fair
that is fair yes yeah
so can you do that can you oh i told you
two things number one just take him out
and say dude i've been competing and i'm
sorry and i'm gonna stop doing that i'm
just gonna stop bringing her up
and um
the second thing is this
i want you to write down on a piece of
paper the things you
feel in competition with her about
okay
she's pretty
um she's hilarious um
she was really smart she had a good job
she made a bajillion dollars she
whatever
whatever when you line yourself up
because i know you do that i still do
that to my wife's old boyfriends and
we've been together like 25 years i mean
it still happens
um and by the way here's how i know my
wife and i have talked about um i had a
girlfriend in high school that is still
a close friend to this day
and she said
for the rest of my life she will always
have five years on me does that make
sense we've been married almost two
decades and it's that little thing in
the back she's just like ugh she's got
five years on me and of course it's it's
like one of those half jokes but half
kind of that's kind of true too and so
here's what i want you i want you to
write down the things you compare then
once you put in a piece of paper i want
you to mail them to me
and when you put them in the mail that
is you saying i'm done i'm letting it go
i'm finished with it okay okay it's
going to be a process that you just and
if you want to get a girlfriend together
and you'll do it together and y'all can
be
mean and ugly and all those things
whatever whatever you need to do
write it down and mail it to me and just
say i'm putting it down i'm done i'm
sitting it down
is that fair okay
yes i will definitely do that if you
don't think you can not compete with her
don't marry this boy
because you're gonna make yourself
miserable you're gonna make him
miserable and your chance of success for
your relationship is gonna be very low
okay okay
okay now i'm gonna tell you the other
answer okay the the lie answer
let's hear it now that we got that one
out of the way
forget her dude you should call hit her
and just be like you ruined it and i've
got him like you're dead is that cool i
don't know i don't know like i don't
have a good go girl speech like in my
heart but that was the best i could do
have you talked to her
no no i've never
i've never we ran into her once
coincidentally on her birthday um in the
city that they grew up in but did you
size her up
immediately no i didn't i didn't know it
was her i was very confused yeah it was
yes you did you knew right away
you knew instantly because he went up
uh she was in a group so i didn't i
didn't see her right away it was on the
water we were yeah we were out in the
water and
anyway it was it was a very awkward
situation
so here's what i want you to do as much
as you can as soon as you feel awkward
lean into it lean into it and laugh even
if it's awkward and you look at him and
go that's awkward
or at some point he may call you the
wrong name
go well that was awkward weirdo
does that make sense has that happened
yeah no not yet
not yet oh you are so geared up for war
let it go
let it go
you won you won you won
okay
you're marrying him he chose you you won
let her go
let her go there's something in when
you're working through um anxiety
there's uh
one of the things we do sometimes when
working with folks who have phobias is
this progressive desensitization
where let's say someone's got a phobia
about snakes and uh
so they may have you draw a picture of a
snake with a crayon and you're just
trying to put you in this position and
ultimately we're leading to we're gonna
show you a picture of a snake and feel
your body and then we're gonna show you
a video of a snake i want you to feel
your body is your heart rate racing
we're gonna we're gonna do this over and
over again until you can see a video of
a snake and your heart rate doesn't take
off on you ultimately this leads to
you're gonna hold a snake we're gonna
take you to the zoo we're gonna give you
one right we're gonna get over this
phobia so maybe you do that with a
friend maybe you get a picture of her
and you just see it
and then you get all fired up and angry
and
and then uh over time eventually you're
just like whatever yeah she's part of
his past
she's part of his past
but he's lucky to have you he's lucky to
have you
just
hey put him in the put him in the mail
put them in the mail and send them to me
i can't wait to get them hey she is
right that facebook is the devil
absolutely yeah and by the way don't go
don't go
on your loved one's parents facebook
page that should just be a rule i'm
going to put that on a john dolan
t-shirt don't go to your
husband or wife's parents facebook page
the only thing that's going to be on
that stuff is sadness and like
weird conspiracy theory links and stuff
like that so yeah stay away good call
good call hey we'll be right back on the
dr john delaney show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right we're back let's take one more
call let's go to erin in
sioux falls south dakota or suke's falls
as they say nobody says that actually
what's up aaron how are you man
hey i'm good dr d how are you
outstanding so what's up brother how can
i help man
well okay so here's my thing i've been
working from home for about 18 months
now what do you do for a living what do
you do for a living
i'm a software engineer
excellent okay so you've been
engineering from the house do you have a
cool setup or you like on top of a
washing machine or something
um i actually i started in
a cleared off desk in my uh bedroom and
then
finally moved me into an office well a
room very
very cool very cool all right man so
you're working from home 18 months
software engineer got your own fancy
home office what's up
um
i i like it a lot but
um just the last couple months
especially i feel like i'm starting to
fall into this trap where
i'm treating my wife more like a
co-worker or a business partner and less
like my spouse and lover
and
it
i don't know i
i feel like
i used to have these nice clear
delineations of
i go to work i'm at work i come home i'm
come home and now i don't really have
any boundaries because it all happens
under the same roof all the time yeah
so give me an example of the way things
used to be and what caused you what
happened that you call caused you to
call to realize dude i got a problem
uh
like used to be like when i went out
and had a commute or
um
i mean
i think one of the things
really recently that was kind of a blow
up between my wife and me
was you know sometimes
when i had an office like i'd you know
need to schedule something with a
with a financial advisor or something
and just be oh okay well you know swing
by we'll grab a break room or be
somebody in-house and you know we'll
grab a break room for 15 minutes and
have a chat
and
i did that recently
and
it was on me i'm stupid um
but i i
scheduled a quick meet with a financial
advisor at the house and forgot to tell
my wife uh i got you
um this was not good
so
it sounds like an honest simple mistake
and you're beating yourself up over it
is this the 15th time this has happened
and she's asked you to not do that or is
she sick of you like that seems rather
benign tell me how it's not
um
i mean this specifically was the first
time this had happened but
i i think it's more
just
i don't know sometimes i like
i don't know if this may even make sense
like
i mean we've been married for 19 years
yeah um
yeah you got little ones
we do
some of them aren't so little anymore
but yeah we've got
we've got five kids
oh
yeah and uh and and she's great she's
been a stay-at-home mom since the first
one was born 16 almost 16 years ago
okay um and we homeschool
oh my gosh
and you know so she's
fantastic at that and sometimes feels
like just running the house as a
business unto itself yeah
but i don't know it it
feels like it was easier
when i went off to work to come home and
be like
there's my lovely wife
there there's my lover
and now it's kind of like i see you
every day
all the time and i'm not sure if you're
my wife or my coworker
who's kind of getting on my nerves and i
can't get away from anymore and i know
i'm sure i'm doing the same thing i know
i'm doing the same thing to her i'm a
guy
so i annoy her and i don't even think
about it or don't even realize it
so number one thank you for calling
for real
um
i know this is not an easy call and i'm
gonna stereotype you but a
it's probably an even more complex call
for a software engineer who's used to
being in their head and
architecting things not even a word but
um
and having to navigate these family
relationships all day every day is just
new okay and i want you to rest in that
millions and millions of people are
dealing with this right now
everybody you know was cool to work from
home and to do these meetings from my
bedroom and to wear sweats during
whatever and we're starting to see folks
desperate to give back to the office
just for
the routine the separation the different
types of relationships all those things
you're talking about experiencing
um and not everybody's gonna be able to
go back or something's gonna be part
time back and so all it to say is you're
in a situation that a bajillion other
people are in and i applaud you for
having the courage to call okay
so
there is a ton going on at your house is
that right
yeah that's five homeschooled kids is 5x
laundry plus 5x learning things plus 5x
people on the internet plus 5x dishes
all that stuff right
yep
and when
you leave and go to work you are right
your wife's the ceo of the house she's
running stuff
right and you're not there to help and
so she knows her roles are clearly
defined as you all have agreed on them
and your roles are clearly defined and
then when everybody's here it gets all
mushed up right
and
so there's two things i think are
important here number one
there is a direct inverse correlation
between
safety and desire safety and romance
familiarity and desire okay
and what happens when you go to work
and you come home even if it's a tiny
bit there's some mystery there that's
that there she is and that's when you
walk on the door and she looks at you
and goes there he is right there's a
little bit of mystery there what's been
going on who's been checking him out
what's she been doing
there's that
it adds some spice if you will
and then when you are in the same
routine he's gonna be wearing this and
talking about that and the same coffee
cup in the same spot in the same sink
man there is no room for mystery and
there's no room for desire and so it
sounds bananas and
and by the way put five kids on top of
this trying to parent during a pandemic
five
um kids plus you worried about your job
and the market and and and
and then on top of that put um
it's hard to
find room for romance with five kids and
20 years of marriage anyway right all
that stuff's there
have you guys stepped away and just said
where are we done a state of the union
of aaron and your wife's marriage have
you all done that
yeah we really haven't okay
you deserve that and she deserves that
how old are your kids
[Applause]
almost 16
14
12
10 and just about eight okay
i think they are old enough if if i mean
obviously you guys do what you need to
do but they're old enough
that you all can get away for a weekend
and it's not a hey we're going to get
away and we're just going to try to
rekindle old romance and i'm gonna put
on some candles and a song that i like
and see if we can make out that might
happen hopefully it does but it's bigger
than that
this is a
state of the union how are we doing i
miss you
all of a sudden this work from home that
started was just gonna be 30 days to
flatten the curve turned into four
months turned into nine months now it's
18 months later
and there's something about just hitting
pause turning all the lights on and
being like hey what's up i miss you
let's be open with one another and it
gives both of you an opportunity to talk
and it starts with i miss you
and i know that i'm not being the guy
that i want to be
i know that if i'm
i'm so impressed with the work you're
doing around here and running the ship
but you and i are becoming co-workers
and i want to get the romance back and i
want to get the desire back and that
leads me to number two you guys have to
practice desire
and so one of the things you've i don't
know if you listen to the show very
often but i always talk about the
analogy that i just beat to death over
and over is
the twin towers
twin towers got hit by those planes and
they fell down we couldn't sweep up all
that glass and all that metal and all
that steel and recreate those towers
they were gone what had to happen is
everything had to be excavated call in
an architect call an engineering firm
and had to rebuild something new
something that's actually stronger some
would say it's more beautiful
and there's a monument to what was but
we're going to build something new
that's what you all guys get to do now
because what was is different what was
is going he used to be dad went to work
he doesn't do that anymore now he's here
and it would give her an opportunity to
speak into i really would love this
right i really would love that here's a
simple solution for
if you need to have meetings at the
house
um and it's you saying i'm so stupid
you're going no it wasn't that it's that
i mentioned this three times and you
didn't hear me those does that make
sense so what you're doing is you're
saying hey we're gonna excavate
everything that was up until now we had
this type of marriage everything's
different because i work from here now
so what is it going to look like what
cool thing can we build moving forward
and how are we going to practice desire
in inside this thing what is our sex
life going to look like what is our
fantasy life together going to look like
what is dating each other going to look
like what is
um going out what is me helping around
the house now that you see me
um what is that going to look like right
does that make sense what i'm saying
aaron
yeah yeah that that makes a lot of sense
and my hope is
that you all approach this with
excitement and vigor of for what could
be
not a mourning of what's lost
you might mourn what was
it used to be cool to have an hour to
yourself to drive and to listen to
whatever podcast you want maybe now that
turns into a morning walk and once
you're done with work you take a walk
around the block for 30 more minutes a
you're going to feel better b you're
going to get some sunshine and see
you've got some markers in your day that
i was working now i'm dad
and same with her she's gonna take a
walk in the morning to gear up for
teaching half dozen kids and then she's
gonna take go to the gym or whatever
that looks like for your family does
that make sense but you're going to
build some of these things in and it
could be exciting and it could be fun
and it could be a new a new canvas y'all
are painting it's only when you try to
recreate what was
that you try to drag the past in the
future that it just wears everybody out
because you can't get it back does that
make sense
yeah
it's really remarkable that you called
this out on yourself that's awesome that
puts you so far ahead of other guys i
know
it's amazing
usually it's a wife calling me saying
hammoth into my rope or a husband
calling and saying we don't have sex
anymore it's my wife's fault and you
peel all the way back and you realize oh
you have five kids you've been working
from home for 18 months in here does
that make sense so you've been able to
look in the mirror and be like i'm
contributing to this i know
i don't know what to do next right so my
recommendation here's my prescription
you all get away for a weekend and dig
into it okay and part of it is gonna be
where are we part of it's gonna be
lamenting what was and then the exciting
part is let's build something awesome
and then we're gonna practice it moving
forward how's that sound
yeah that i like that i think
i think that's something we can
definitely do and
then and move forward with something
cool i love that and if it's really rad
if you all come back with some um here's
who we are right um here's who we're
going to be here's what our marriage is
going to look like it's going to look
different and then you invite the kids
in on it
they'll all roll their eyes like gross
no i don't talk about this
bring him in on it here's who we're
going to be moving forward this is how
this is going to work
um we're going to make this work because
this looks like this is the rest of our
life it's not but it feels like it is
and then in 18 months you're going to
get called back to the office you know
guys are going to go on another retreat
and do this whole thing over again
we had this rhythm and now the rhythm is
different now we're playing a different
song as a family and so what's that
going to look like
um you're a stud aaron i appreciate you
a lot and i want to know how that
retreat goes so after you go on this
retreat send kelly an email let us know
how it goes and if i can help with
anything moving forward let me know
appreciate you man all right as we wrap
up today's show
we had another song but in honor of
alicia
in honor of alicia
it's a song
from the record
some things i know
from is it leanne womack
i'm not a womack fan but i am now what's
the name of the song i'll think of a
reason later and it goes like this
oh yeah this is my favorite song of all
time by the way guys
i heard he was gonna marry some girl
from denver then my sister came over and
had the sunday paper with her and there
was this girl on the social page looking
in love and all engaged we decided that
she don't take a very good picture and
it may be my family's redneck nature
rubbing off bringing out unladylike
behavior it sure ain't christian to
judge a stranger but i don't like her
this is awesome kelly she may be an
angel who spends all winter bringing the
homeless blankets and dinner a regular
nobel peace prize winner but i really
hate her and i'll think of a reason
later that's fantastic that's kind of
how you this song feels like your song
kelly kind of how do you say that i mean
because you're incredible that's why
really all right
and the best senior associate executives
our producer of all time right here on
the dr john dolani show